hello hey Kevin it's Jerry how's my
favorite co-worker doing what do you
want nothing I was just wondering if
maybe you could come in like a half hour
early so I could bounce at 4:30 again
well come on then it's Friday it's
finally spring I just want to get a head
start on my weekend before the traffic
hits yeah you might want to reconsider
that traffic's been crazy all across the
city some kind of major accident or
something have you heard no I haven't
heard anything let me just check my
window how's the view out there it's
beautiful
all right well listen I'll try to go
over there early but no promises okay oh
hey um quick 80s movies nine-letter clue
is struck buck the Empire Strikes Back
mmm higher awesome you are a doll I will
see you when you get here
generalizer coming with me
you
anyway we have a prostitute tango in
Sector seven I have authorization from
the President of the United States to
authorize you to push the button
authorization code alpha Charlie
you